TO YOU AS THEY COME IN.
TIME NOW FOR OUR "SEEN AND
UNSEEN" SEGMENT, WHERE WE EXPOSE
THE BIG CULTURAL STORIES OF THE
DAY.
THE NFL JOINS FORCES WITH A
MUSIC GIANT, AND BERNIE SANDERS
PAIRS OFF WITH CARDI B.
JOINING US NOW WITH ALL THE
DETAILS IS RAYMOND ARROYO,
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
RAYMOND, TELL US ABOUT THIS
UNBELIEVABLE PRESS CONFERENCE
THAT TOOK PLACE TODAY,
ANNOUNCING A NEW PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN THE NFL AND JAY-Z.
>> Raymond: JESSE, THE
COLIN KAEPERNICK KNEELING
PROTEST DURING THE
NATIONAL ANTHEM AND RAGED NFL
FANS.
WHILE INSPIRING SOME OF THE NFL
PLAYERS -- TO CHANNEL THE PLAYER
PROTEST OVER WHAT THEY DESCRIBED
AS POLICE BRUTALITY ON THIS
NIGHT OF ALL NIGHTS, THE NFL
COMMITTED $89 MILLION TO
SOMETHING CALLED "INSPIRE
CHANGE," THAT IS THEIR SOCIAL
JUSTICE PROGRAM.
TODAY, ROGER CADDELL APPEARED
WITH THE MAN HEADLINING THAT
EFFORT FOR THE NFL, JAY-Z.
>> THIS PARTNERSHIP, IN ADDITION
TO THE ENTERTAINMENT ASPECT,
BRINGING FOOTBALL AND MUSIC TO
TOGETHER, GOING TO MAKE EVEN
GREATER CHANGE.
WE CALL IT PROTEST PROGRESS
BEARD WE NEED TO MAKE PROGRESS
WITH COMMUNITIES.
>> JUST HAVING A PLACE WHERE WE
CAN HAVE THESE CONVERSATIONS,
THINGS ARE GOING WRONG IN THE
COUNTRY, YOU KNOW, PEOPLE ARE
DIANE, IN THESE NEIGHBORHOODS,
OKAY, WHERE DO WE GO, AGAIN,
EVERYONE, IT'S A NATURAL EMOTION
TO BE UPSET, BUT WHERE DO WE GO
NOW?
WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO?
HOW DO WE FIX IT?
>> Raymond: THE IDEA HERE,
JESSE, IS TO USE MUSIC AND
SOCIAL ACTIVISM TO CHANGE
SOCIETY.
JAY-Z, DURING THE PRESSER,
IDENTIFIED POLICE BRUTALITY AS
THE TARGET OF THEIR EFFORTS.
NOW THIS IS THE GUY WHO GRAFTED
THIS, INCIDENTALLY.
♪ ♪
♪♪ YOUR STOPPING ME BECAUSE I'M
YOUNG AND I'M BLACK ♪
♪ DO I LOOK LIKE A MIND READER ♪
♪ I DON'T KNOW ♪♪
>> Raymond: TURNED DOWN
PERFORMING AT THE SUPER BOWL.
NOW IT'S A HUGE PLATFORM, NO
DOUBT WORTH MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
LIKE THAT, JAY-Z SAID HE IS
WILLING TO WORK WITH PEOPLE WHO
HE DISAGREES WITH POLITICALLY.
THAT'S NOT A BAD THING.
THAT, I WILL COMMEND HIM FOR.
BUT LET'S NOT LOSE SIGHT OF WHAT
THE NFL IS.
IT'S FOOTBALL!
I'M QUITE CERTAIN THESE FANS ARE
NOT PAYING HIGH PRICES TO
PROTEST COPS, PARTICULARLY WITH
WHAT YOU COVERED EARLIER TONIGHT
IN PHILADELPHIA.
I THINK THAT IS THE LAST THING
ON THE MINDS OF NFL FANS.
BUT THEY -- THE NFL -- NEED TO
EMBRACE JAY-Z'S VISION OF SOCIAL
JUSTICE BID THIS IS A GUY WHO
STOLE DRUGS, STABBED HIS BROTHER
IN THE FACE, BUT STILL THIS
PARTNERSHIP IS
BEING BILLED AS A WAY TO UNIFY
AMERICA.
AS MEMORY SERVES, JAY-Z HAD A
HARD TIME YOU'RE FLYING WITH HIS
SISTER-IN-LAW, SOLANGE KNOWLES.
>> AS SOON AS THE DOORS CLOSED,
BEYONCE'S TO START WITH HER
ATTENTION JAY-Z, SEEMINGLY
SHOUTING AT HIM, PUNCHING AND
KICKING HIM, AND FINALLY
SMACKING HIM WITH HER PURSE.
>> Raymond: OKAY
>> Jesse: OKAY, THIS IS MY
FIRST RAYMOND ARROYO SEGMENT,
BUT A LOSS FOR WORDS.
I WOULD SAY THIS, RAYMOND.
IT SEEMS LIKE BIG ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE THE NFL, OR LIKE NIKE IS
DOING WITH KAEPERNICK, THEY ARE
BRINGING ON THE SOCIAL JUSTICE
LIAISONS TO HELP THEM NAVIGATE
THROUGH TENDER ISSUES, RACIAL
ISSUES, THINGS LIKE THAT, THAT
MIGHT GIVE THESE BIG
ORGANIZATIONS PROBLEMS, AND IF
YOU BRING A GUY WITH STREET
CRED, EARS TO THE STREET, GREAT
CREDIBILITY IN THE BLACK
COMMUNITY, THAT CAN KIND OF
CUSHION ANY SORT OF NEGATIVE
PRESS THAT ORGANIZATION COULD
FACE.
>> Raymond: JESSE, THERE IS AN
OUT -- LOOK.
THEY'RE TRYING TO BUY CRED IN
THE COMMUNITY COME UP WITH THE
NFL IS DOING.
JAY-Z WILL HAVE CREATIVE CONTROL
OVER WHO SINGS AT THE
SUPER BOWL, WHO IS PART OF NFL
PRODUCTIONS.
THIS IS A MAJOR --
>> Jesse: HE GETS TO PICK THE
SUPER BOWL HALFTIME SHOW?
>> Raymond: YES, HE DOES.
>> Jesse: WHAT?
>> Raymond: YES.